thank you very much to
was for that very warm welcome and
congratulations on your English which is
actually more beautiful than mine
because you think about each sentence
and pronounce it correctly and obviously
I have now been put in a very difficult
position because I know I'm I'm talking
to a largely hostile audience and I came
here in the hope that that you all had
open minds perhaps your minds are open
even though your conclusions are closed
let's hope Thomas just raised the
question which is apparently being
discussed here of what it is to be a
European and I gather my friend Pritz
Boca Stein has said that he counts
himself as a European because he was
born in a European Union country and
that is a remarkable definition I count
myself as a European first of all
because I was born in a European country
not a European Union country because it
wasn't part of it then but much more
importantly because I am heir to the
Christian faith the Roman law and the
civilization of Europe embodied in its
institutions its universities and in
above all in its Parliament's and his
political procedures which to me is the
most important fact of my own upbringing
and I think those my country embodies
those traditions as European traditions
as well as any other country in Europe
and has done perhaps more than any other
country in Europe to defend them so
inevitably therefore I don't think that
whatever it is that makes the people of
Britain wants to move away from the
European Union whatever it is is really
a proof that they are not European on
the contrary I think many British people
certainly of my persuasion would say
that it's precisely our nature as
Europeans that makes us move in the
direction that we're moving that we
become doubtful about the European Union
because it does not represent Europe
does not represent the Europe that we
know and love and which made us the
civilized
things that we are or at least some of
us now so let me just say why I think
the British people feel so doubtful
about the European Union I think there
are three big reasons which are not
often put into discussion which which
perhaps ought to be known by people in
this room the first is the post-war
situation we the British had
successfully defended our sovereignty
against Nazi aggression and had not been
occupied all other nations save Spain
Portugal and Sweden which maintained a
kind of neutrality had suffered defeat
and/or occupation and this means there's
an enormous difference in the underlying
psyche of the British people's
particular my parents generation who had
fought that war protected our country
came from it came away from that war
with a sense of having achieved what
they set out to do which was to protect
our freedom independence and sovereignty
from a major threat to which other
countries had succumbed and I think this
means that that there we start from a
different premise the premise that we
have earned our freedom we've defended
our freedom and in doing so defended
Europe the European values against the
most recent attempt to submerge them
which was the attempt of the Nazis of
course then there was the attempt of the
Communists which is another question
coming later of hope for most of us so
the motives for us British people to
surrender our sovereignty to a
transnational body politic
or inevitably different even if they
existed at all they weren't the same
motives as the Germans had or the French
had who had survived occupation and the
enmity between them and wanted a new
kind of reconciliation we didn't need
that reconciliation because we had never
been forced to have it thrust upon us
so our parents asked the question was
the fight worth it
just to give in just to surrender that
thing that we had spent our lives and
fortunes on defending and I think that
question is it always been in the back
of minds of the British people as one
reason why they've been skeptical about
attempts to take national sovereignty
away so that's the first big reason and
that the British are skeptical the
second big reason is that our country
has enjoyed a different kind of
government and a different kind of law
from the rest of Europe the rest of the
Europe has largely not all of it but
most of it has undergone the great
transformation inflicted upon it by
Napoleon and the imposition upon upon
the nations of Europe of external
sovereignty recent constitutions and the
Napoleonic jurisdiction the code
Napoleon your country used to have a
beautiful system of law Roman Dutch law
which survives in the modern world but
only in the places which were part of
the British Empire because we stole them
from you
that's to say Zimbabwe you used to be
Rhodesia and South Africa forget about
that the fact is that that the
Netherlands are governed by a Napoleonic
style jurisdiction in which law is
imposed upon people from above by the
decisions of the legislature and works
down into those capillaries of society
in my country law is not largely or
wasn't largely imposed from above but
was created in the courts and indeed to
say that it was created is already to
beg an important question the British
people regarded the courts of law courts
of the common law as it's called as
discovering the law you take your
dispute to a judge and the conflict that
is really troubling you you put it
before that judge and if he is impartial
and proceeds according to the principles
of natural justice as they're called
then
he will discover the legal solution even
if nobody has ever said it before
Parliament then has the business of
ratifying this if it comes before
Parliament but much of our law has never
come before Parliament and this is an
extraordinary fact that we have built up
a legal system from below from the
resolution of the conflicts that occur
between ordinary people and only our now
and then with the intervention of the
legislature imposing laws from above you
can understand this if you contrast the
law of products liability in English law
with the laws all the laws and
regulations about product liability
which have been created by the European
Commission and the the European Court of
Justice we have one law which is not
even a law it's a decision of the courts
in the case of Donoghue against
Stevenson which tells you that somebody
who is issuing something for sale so
that in the general public is prima
facie liable for all the adverse causes
that will adverse effects that would
result from consuming it that was a
decision of the common law courts and it
has been sufficient to generate a fully
developed system of product liability
without consulting Parliament cause
Parliament comes in but then when there
is an additional difficulty but that
particular innovation saved us from all
the problems that that bothered European
states in the in the interregnum it
interwar period right so that I think is
in a very important point to remember
that our system of law is structurally
completely different from those systems
of laws are applied in Europe has great
difficulty accommodating things like the
decisions of the European Court of
Justice and certainly causes feelings of
rebellion in people's in the minds of
ordinary people when they find
themselves subject to a regime of
regulation which is vast
by a hundredfold than anything that
they've been accustomed to and that I
think is important because it gives
people a sense that somehow we are being
governed from outside by people who
don't understand us who only know how to
to regulate and don't know how to
resolve conflicts regulations produce as
many conflicts as they resolve the
common law only resolves things but
that's the second great feature of my
country which makes it so skeptical
towards the European Union but the third
feature I think is one which hardly ever
mentioned but is even more important
than the other two which is that we
speak the international language indeed
we speak it so we're so deeply immersed
in it that we hardly speak anything else
we are a Monogue lot a highly ignorant
community which doesn't have any ability
to understand anything in any language
other than its own but the language that
we speak is the first language that
everybody else learns so anybody who is
remotely educated from any part of
Europe can move into our country and
establish himself or herself in our
territory at the same time our territory
is small very small it's much loved -
because we fought for it in two world
wars and this was the great propaganda
message that we had this beautiful
country which must be saved
and anybody who's travelled in the
British countryside knows what I mean
it's much loved and protected protected
by long-standing institutions and
initiatives which I am going to talk
about tomorrow in Amsterdam at a meeting
organized by the European Union
interestingly enough any this is a it's
a small territory our territory is even
more densely populated this territory of
England at least than that of the of the
Netherlands it you wouldn't think so to
look at it so we are effectively under
siege due to the European Union's
freedom of movement provisions which
bring half a million people
each year into our tiny country and
those provisions are part of the treaty
deeply embedded in the treaty almost
impossible to change and they are the
things which are most objectionable to
the British who see that they have lost
control of their borders and are now
hosts to vast number of people from the
former communist countries in Eastern
Europe who compete for jobs of course
and most of all compete the houses and a
in effect causing an enormous housing
crisis which we don't know how to
resolve so again this goes back to the
first big reason you know the fact that
we defended our sovereignty in a time of
great emergency and people ask
themselves how can there be such a thing
as national sovereignty if we have lost
the right to control your borders you
can't exclude those whom you don't want
in the country or invite it will make
give special privileges to those whom
you do so those three great features of
my country's position which are not
duplicated elsewhere in Europe are the
real underlying cause as to why British
people feel so dissatisfied you may
object to them feeling dissatisfied in
that on these grounds you may think that
this is primitive or in some way
involves a kind of the kind of
nationalistic consciousness from which
the rest of the world has released its
itself but I think that it probably is
not really fair because these feelings
come from a deep sense of a political
order that is endured for a thousand
years it's we are not nationalists as is
proved by the fact that we don't have a
single nation therefore nations wrapped
together in the United Kingdom but none
of which accept how possibly the Scots
have recently expressed their national
feelings in belligerent belligerent
terms but all of whom think that they
share this great political tradition and
the land
in which it has established itself and
they share also the law that I was
referring to we have to add to these
those three facts two very basic
observations first that the European
Union has in its enthusiasm for
dissolving borders left itself
unprotected against mass migrations
German guilt feelings of course make
this worse and there's no point in
hiding from the fact that we're all
extremely worried about what is going to
be the consequences of angular Aguila
commercials gestures in recent weeks
it's there no limit to the people that
we are going to welcome and if so are we
forced to accept
however crowded we are have a little
review resources we have to offer are we
forced to accept a complete transfer of
populations into a country which has
fought to protect itself from just that
very thing from the labels realm
ambitions of its neighbors are we to
ignore factors like knowledge religion
adaptability culture in incorporating
new communities in our midst that's a
review june that the European Union has
fudged and forbidden assent that in many
ways from discussing the second
observation is that to be governed by a
treaty is to put yourself in this
situation where you can't adapt to
change
each nation can localize its problems
and solve them or adapt to them if it
can take legislative initiatives on its
own and that's the normal way in which
countries face their problems try to
adapt to changing circumstances and to
go on into the future they pass laws or
create institutions initiate discussions
which enable them to take a decision for
themselves but if they can't take that
decision how are they going to adapt the
treaty is it needs the signature of all
its members to change in any very basic
respect but it was a treaty signed over
50 years ago
people who are dead in a situation that
has vanished why should we be still
governed by that rather than by our own
decisions taken in our own Parliament's
according to our own sense of what our
problems are surely this is irrational
when Lenin imposed communism on the
Soviet you what became the Soviet Union
he destroyed all the institutions in
which opposition could take shape
not just the parliamentary institutions
but the legal institutions - abolishing
the courts and and the legal profession
and all the rest so that there was no
reverse gear and the Soviet Union went
on for 70 years
until it finally met the brick wall
which had been there all along building
a political order without a reverse gear
or without a bit an ability to change in
accordance with the needs at the moment
is the greatest political mistake is the
mistake of making a political order
which won't recognize mistakes and
that's what we after what I think the
European Union has done by attaching all
of its procedures to a treaty signed in
a situation that has vanished
so out of this there is a arisen a
strong sense that there's not just a
democratic deficit in the European
process which in many countries admit
that there is but a deficit of
legitimacy in the whole thing that the
European processes confiscated national
sovereignty but offered nothing in
exchange great and now of course here
people give lots of economic arguments
and of course they're very complicated
economic arguments to which I give two
replies before stopping because I know
that you don't accept anything that I've
said so far so I might as well get the
whole lot down so you guys have some
more things not to accept
first of all the economic arguments
don't tend in one direction a customs
union of course amplifies trade and
therefore prosperity but the European
Union regime of regulations cuts against
that
giving a competitive edge to countries
on the Pacific Rim and controlling hours
of work and conditions of labor in ways
that make the European Union nations
uncompetitive in the modern global
economy now these matters are complex
and I've discovered that no expert
agrees that any other and the evidence
of history in my view is that all
economists are self-appointed
authorities and that all their judgments
are wrong but you know that's only my
view this the second reply to this is
that the argument is not about economics
anyway it's about identity who are we
imagine persuading people to share their
house and their land with a family whose
manners and values they cannot accept on
the grounds that they will be twice as
wealthy if they do so their response
would be you know okay that's great that
we would be twice as wealthy but we
wouldn't have what we really want which
is our love for each other our
attachment to this place and our ability
to govern ourselves according to our own
way of life and you know that seems a
perfectly reasonable response and one of
the great questions that this whole
debate raises is whether there are not
other values and economic ones in the
world in which we live
politicians as soon as they're given a
question to answer they collapse the
question into economics say will be
worse off if we do this better if we do
that and so on
even though economic questions only come
after all the other questions the
questions of our integrity sovereignty
and freedom and that's what it is all
about thank